the March for Life takes on a new
purpose on Friday the annual Gathering
of thousands of anti-abortion Rights
activists was held for the first time
since the Supreme Court overturned Roe
versus Wade with abortion no longer
protected by the Constitution Chief
election and campaign correspondent
Robert Costa looks at what that means
for the March the movement and the
politics going forward
how far should that fight go it's a
battle that will continue I think when I
say a battle it's not a physical battle
but I mean it's a spiritual battle for
the soul of this nation Evangelical
leader Franklin Graham son of the famed
Billy Graham was one of thousands of
anti-abortion activists who turned up in
Washington Friday for the March for Life
arguing that the end of row is not the
end of their fight after the midterms
last year where does the abortion issue
go from here
well I think the pro-life movement has
always been strongest at the Grassroots
level so
Rose overturned but we still have a lot
of work to do but the persistence from
conservatives on abortion comes as the
Republican party is at a Crossroads some
like former president Donald Trump have
blamed last year's disappointing
election results on the abortion issue
being poorly handled by Republicans who
insisted on no exceptions on abortion
and I've made it very clear it may take
us as long
to restore the sanctity of life to the
center of American law as it took us to
overturn Roe v Wade but I believe that
far beyond the politics of that question
for the sake of the nation we need to
restore
uh the sanctity of life but in the early
days of the 2024 presidential race some
possible Trump Rivals are shaking their
heads at Trump's assessment moving to
the right and challenging the
competition to take further action and
would you nudge Governor DeSantis to
take further action I would nudge every
Governor to do what they can to back up
their pro-life record I think that that
talking about
um situations and making statements is
incredibly important but also taking
action and governing and bringing
policies to protect life are even more
important because that's what truly will
save lives Governor Christie gnome of
South Dakota where abortion is banned
has been challenging Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis and other Rising
Republicans to do more to limit
abortions in their states sparking an
informal policy standoff among those who
might run for president DeSantis signed
a 15-week abortion ban into law last
year and another possible candidate
governor Glenn Younkin is now pushing a
15-week ban in Virginia but many
attending the March acknowledged the
politics of an issue that has long been
highly charged remains complicated do
you believe Republicans should push more
or less on this issue
you know
what we're doing is in the right
direction currently I think that they
need to be willing
Democrats need to be willing to have a
dialogue with Republicans too meanwhile
Democrats continue to push on this issue
as well and on Sunday vice president
Kamala Harris will deliver a major
address on abortion rights in Florida
five decades after Roe v Wade for CBS
Saturday morning Robert Costa Washington